There are many different styles of review. Here’s a brief list of some notable
ones. The class resources page points you to further information about them.
What we’ve been talking about are sometimes called Fagan reviews. Fagan was
an IBM researcher, her, who first studied them and proposed the structuring that
we’re, we’re talking about. But a a more recent and alternative approach is
called pair programming, which is part of extreme programming,
an agile development method and this was studied by Laura, Laurie Williams.
It suggests that review is part is performed synchronously with, with coding or
developing of an artifact by having a partner looking over the coder's shoulder
pointing out problems at the time that that coder is, is, is doing his or
her job or that the designer is doing their design. Another alternative is
what's called pass-around reviews. These are typically conducted by email.
This is often applied in open source projects where the people aren't collocated
and the source code management system alerts participants to take a look when
a new change or new file has been checked into the source control system.
And in any of these approaches there's a possibility of applying tools.
Tools might be differencers to compare versions the source control management
system itself as I've, as I've indicated, and there're also program analyzer
tools that can provide enforcement and feedback and examples here are Lint. You
may have heard of the Lint program or CodeCheck, which is a plugin into Eclipse.